let's do it
[Applause]
all right so you want to put cuffs on
him
Hi man is Richard here yeah can you have
him come to the door please
sure absolutely
they're here I don't know who they are
stop Brunswick please South Brunswick
Police just so you know we're uh audio
visually recording
down here
come on down this way how are you how
you doing
come here real quick
okay
all right just so you know where there's
a uh
a warrant out of Volusia County Florida
okay for the incident that you're aware
of what's going on yeah I was I was uh I
think I saw you there what you talked
about yeah yeah right okay okay
we'll do everything
um
search version for uh electronic devices
um what's upstairs your computer can I
get uh
yeah shoes in a sweatshirt
well yeah Pat them down we'll have a
seat and then we'll go up to your room
where's your cell phone uh it should be
um upstairs
um
and this is a copy of the search warrant
yeah
it's for his for his uh room we're gonna
get computer devices uh phones whatnot
and now come with us I'll uh write your
receipts we have everything that we took
okay
kind of smells like a chin lock right
here sorry okay no it's not okay